parce qu'il ya une différence quand même
autre la dette publique et la dette
privée entre un ménage il est mortel la
fin de sa vie donc j'ai d'avoir
remboursé sa dette
une entreprise elle peut faire en partie
couvert sa lettre mais classe b to c
privée donc c'est plus fragiles l'état
mais depuis les états modernes mais
depuis des lustres et dans tous les pays
du monde
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils font courir
leur dette c'est à dire qu'ils sont en
train de rembourser parce qu'ils sont
immortels et c'est pas gênant là où ça
devient gênant
bien entendu c'est quand la dette ne
vient pas soutenable mais la rue du
rhône absolument pas ce problème de
soutenabilité l'enjeu
je suis sûr vous serez la chronique
d'aujourd'hui c'est que l'économie ne
s'effondre pas et l'enjeu de rond point
de vue c'est non seulement doté de
l'intervention publique sous forme de
déficit et de dette pour relancer
l'économie y compris privés mais l'enjeu
aussi c'est de dire de saisir cette
occasion qu'on n'a pas saisi en 2008
pour changer de données elle changer de
modèle ça veut dire quoi ça ne pas dire
en finir avec l'économie privée s'est
terminée ce ton là bien entendu on a
quitté le 20e siècle
ça veut dire que il faut rompre avec ce
qu'on appelle le néolibéralisme la
finance libéralisée qui étouffe des
entreprises c'est toutes les logiques
productive le le libre échange il faut
remettre des règles du commerce
international
on l'a vu sur la question d'un cornichon
les tests des masques étaient kara et
puis austérité salariale
parce que c'est aussi cette austérité
qui a creusé les dettes un modèle
néolibéral c'est au fait de l'austérité
qui ont dit aux gens il faut quand même
continuer à dépenser pour soutenir
l'activité des entreprises privées donc
en été nous mais ce qui a beaucoup
augmenté ces dernières années
c'est pas simplement les dettes
publiques à cause du néolibéralisme
c'est aussi les dettes privées des
ménages et des entreprises
en france la dette des entreprises ne le
savaient pas voir a beaucoup monté ces
dernières années
[Musique]